hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner tochter
ich stehe heute nicht um meine eigenen
küche bis nämlich grad in der türkei im
urlaub und wir haben jetzt die ganze
zeit draußen gegessen und jetzt möchte
ich jetzt mal wieder was eigenes machen
wir sind auch hier so ein bisschen
alleine sache
wir haben nämlich keinen pauschalurlaub
gewusst sondern sind einfach in der
kleinen hugo und können wir jeden tag
bestimmen was wir machen was wir essen
und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
hier in der september lenkt deutschen
klassiker macht weil die das hier gar
nicht kennen
und ich habe ein paar restaurants ein
paar rezepte gekommen und ja die
bekommen einmal von mir die deutschen
rezepte und ich nehme die türkischen
rezepte mit und ich möchte heute einen
zwetschgenkuchen machen mit streuseln
als im klassiker bei uns in deutschland
und es wird aus jeder teil gemacht und
quetschungen oder planung gelegt und
dann mit so leckeren mit sträußen
gemacht und ich zeige ich jetzt hier
einfach mal die zutaten für den hefeteig
brauchen wir drei 100 gramm mehl 40 g
zucker 1 einem halben würfel hefe
einhalten teelöffel salz 40 gramm butter
und etwa 100 bis 150 milliliter milch
das ist alles ins zimmer und steht jetzt
ja auch schon eine weile rum und da wir
hier auf 40 grad haben hat es auch die
perfekte temperatur dann brauchen wir
ein klub laune oder eben zweitstimmen
und für die zehn streusel brauchen
150 gramm mehl 90 gramm zucker 90 gramm
butter und einen teelöffel zimt wenn
natürlich keine zinsmarkt kann den sind
einfach auch weglassen
ich habe ziele türkei ist auch probleme
gehabt zutaten zu bekommen ich wollte
ursprünglich ein panna cotta machen habe
aber weder gelatine gefunden
und deswegen wird es kein akuter rezept
erst machen wenn wir wieder daheim sind
ich werde einfach mal den hefeteig
zubereitet und zeigt euch wie das
funktioniert es gebe jetzt zuerst mal
die hefe in meine kleinen glasschüssel
ihr könnt es natürlich auch mehr mixa
machen und rück gerät oder auch mit
namen kitchen ältere kennen oder was
auch immer ich habe jetzt gar nichts
davon da deswegen wir die substanz
traditionellen behandeln habt ihr ein
bisschen von zucker 1 gegeben
ein wenig mehr ganz wenigen kurz zum
auflösen
es ist hier die hefe auf gps in mich
rein und bei den mädels kann ich euch
gar nicht sagen wie viel genau man
braucht weil wir haben auch noch 1 1
und da jedes ei unterschiedlich groß ist
sind sie etwa zwischen 100 und 150
restlichen zu kommen
jetzt gebe ich das mehl ein
ein pinkfarbenes werkzeug begleitet
zugute
die kann man auch verlassen muss man
auch nicht jetzt werde ich das einfach
ein kneten und wenn ich mir hätte ich
glaube etwas flüssigkeit
der teig sondern richtig schön bei nicht
zu fest
schon ein bisschen komisch erarbeitet
den kreis oder steht
jetzt gnädig den teig einfach so lange
bis er nicht mehr klebt ihr könnt sehen
ich habe jetzt auch nichts mehr dazu
gegeben meine hände sind von ganz
alleine wieder sauber geworden
und wenn man den teig verknetet es
vielleicht drei minuten dann wird der
fall eine wunderschön und ihr sind auch
dass es oben küchenmaschine geht die
zeit spezielle facebook was thomas
würdest du alles irgendwie aus artisten
branche irgendwie unfertig rolle drehen
und knetet den hauptsache durchgeknetet
je länger man hebe teig knetet umso
schöner wird
den gebe ich jetzt einfach jeder zurück
in die schüssel neben noch ein bisschen
von dieser butter diese noch im keller
wieder da nicht klebt gebt mir als auch
daran denken mit einem küchentuch ab und
werde in dieser zeit schon mal die
pflaumen vorbereiten und die strophen
problem
wir sind ihr einfach die zweitstimmen
und könnte einmal halbieren und den kern
entfernen und ihr könnt den fugen
übrigens auch mit mirabellen zum
beispiel nach hinten einfach halbieren
und der kern kommt aus und so macht ihr
dann die ganzen sätzen
glauben sie es gewaschen und geputzt und
entkernt und jetzt kann ich plötzlich
streusel vorbereiten dafür nehme ich mir
jetzt einfach eine schüssel daran jemals
auf die planerin oder frettchen drin
und dafür möchte ich das jetzt einfach
alles also der zucker und die channel
und sich kurz mit diesen bug löffel und
ihm dann die hände
so sollten dann die streusel aussehen
also wenn man sie zusammen drückt
bleiben sie fest auch sollen eher etwas
größer und ich werde es einfach noch
warten bis der hefeteig aufgeht das
dauert den bruch etwa ein halbe stunde
bei mir bisher sich einfach schön
verdoppelt hat und dann geht es mit
diesem rezept gleich weiter und wenn der
hilfen aufgegangen ist könnt ihr auf den
ofen vorheizen auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze wenn teig ist jetzt richtig
schön aufgegangen das sieht man auch
hier der hat fast das dreifache volumen
angenommen und den gebe ich jetzt
einfach auf mein vorbereitet das
backpapier da klebt auch gar nicht und
natürlich könnt ihr hier auch die back
folie nehmen allerdings müsst ihr die
dann vor dem anschneiden des kuchens
natürlich entfernen weil die ansonsten
kaputt geht
mit nur aus rollstuhl ich dann den teig
gleichmäßig aus ich habe jetzt hier nur
einen aus holz der klebt auch ein
bisschen ich brauche auch gleich noch
ein bisschen mehl dafür mit einem
silikon aus rund start geht das ganze
natürlich besser den habe ich zu hause
den verlinkt ich euch auch in meiner
infobox und dann habe ich das ganze in
meinem backblech hinein und hält da auch
mit den händen noch mal nach und
verteilen den teig richtig schön was er
einfach schön gleichmäßig und glatt wird
danach lasse ich ihn noch mal eine halbe
stunde aufgehen und werde dann die
zwetschgen oder die pflaumen oder eben
das obst einfach schön gleichmäßig
darauf verteilen
ihr könnt das obst auch gern kleine
schneiden aber so finde ich es viel
schöner
anschließend verteile ich noch die
streusel group darüber einfach mit den
händen etwas trüber geben
den kuchen lasse ich dann noch mal für
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten auf gehen bevor
in baku der hefeteig ist schön
aufgegangen wie man sehen kann
jetzt gebe ich den kuchen für etwa 25
bis 30 minuten einfach bis die
oberfläche schön goldbraun ist ihren
ofen bei 180 grad und dann sehen wir uns
das wieder
mein kumpel länger gebraucht weiter
offen ihr nicht so funktioniert wie bei
mir zu hause und ihr erkennt ob er
fertig ist sie einfach mit deiner
kuchentafel hier unten reinschaut
anwendertag unten auch dazu frauen ist
sogar die zweite ihn einfach mal wieder
runter ziehen damit ich nicht dem
backblech schneiden muss stücke
schneiden
und so sieht dann der fertige
ganz unten dieser schöne pokale verteilt
dann die säuren laugen ins netz stellte
leckeres im streit
ihr seht also auch richtige werkzeug zur
hand hat und klassiker immer machen
wollen hefeteig oder gezeigt oder
anführt hat die oma höher auf immer ohne
geräte gemacht und ich werde einfach
noch die nachbarschaft mit kuchen
versorgen mit einem deutschen petschel
punkten in der türkei und dieses rezept
gibt es natürlich zum nachlesen auf
www.stayguest.de ich freue mich
natürlich wenn mir mein rezept und einen
kommentar ab vielleicht macht ihr euren
zwetschgenkuchen anders ich habe ja auch
schon mal den zwischenrufen mit beige
book gemacht den ich letztes jahr bei
den topf geld gemacht habe mehr einsätze
für zwetschgen hat und das auf kuchen
hat kann auch den machen den verlinkt
ich euch einfach in einer infobox
und ich gehe ich jetzt etwas abkühlen
war mir sehen dann bin ich ganz
geschützt weil es hier einfach zu wenig
geld eine runde schwimmen